the limited edition twelve thousand and
twenty three quartz gazard calendar is
here every purchase enables us to make
videos free for everyone so get one for
yourself for a loved one and be a
sponsor of the following video
Eternal gratitude from us and all the
burbs around the world
here in the cortexart labs we test very
important ideas to see what happens when
you blow things up or play with black
holes many of you suggested that we look
into an idea that sounds reasonable
shooting nuclear waste into space it's
one of those Concepts that seems like an
easy fix for one of the main problems
with the nuclear energy but it turns out
this idea is not just bad but horribly
bad and it gets worse the longer you
think about it why is that
foreign
what is nuclear waste
clear waste is a fuzzy term and comes in
categories which vary from country to
country but in general there are three
broad levels ninety percent is low level
nuclear waste tools gloves or trash used
at a nuclear facility that could be
weakly contaminated with some
short-lived radioactivity this stuff is
generally safe for normal disposal seven
percent is intermediate level nuclear
waste mostly materials that have been in
close proximity to a reactor core long
enough to become dangerously Radioactive
with proper handling it's either safely
buried or melted down and mixed into
glass or concrete and stored deep
underground so 97 of nuclear waste is
similar to toxic byproducts from other
Industries not great not terrible we can
handle it the remaining three percent is
where our problems begin
high-level nuclear waste is very
concentrated spent fuel taken out of a
reactor core
formerly uranium it's now made of
various dangerous and often highly
radioactive elements as a bonus it's
also incredibly hot and not easy to
handle at all this is what we want to
shoot into space All In All Around 440
active nuclear reactors create about 11
000 tons of high-level nuclear waste
each year since 1954 we've accumulated
400 000 tons of dangerous radioactive
waste most countries are dealing with it
by not dealing with it and kicking the
can towards the future great so let's
launch it into space according to
scientists space is big and nobody lives
there so it seems perfect for eating
away this mess there are a few tiny
problems though problem one stuff ain't
cheap
even though space flight is getting more
affordable it's still extremely
expensive
to get something into low earth orbit
costs on average about four thousand
dollars per kilogram
putting that into perspective it costs
about 1 600 to mine separate and
fabricate one kilogram of nuclear fuel
so launching waste into space has
suddenly made nuclear fuel for reactors
way more expensive and greatly increased
the cost of the electricity they produce
to launch one reactor's worth of nuclear
waste would cost at least 100 million
dollars per year
to deal with all the 440 operational
nuclear power plants high-level nuclear
waste would cost some 44 billion dollars
per year for space launch before
packaging transport and security costs
are added
okay let's pretend we don't care
currently we couldn't shoot all the
nuclear waste into space even if we
wanted to there just aren't enough
Rockets
in 2021 we saw a record 135 launches
into space if we repurposed each of
those rockets and filled them all with
nuclear waste the total amount that
could be lifted into a low earth orbit
which is the closest orbit above the
atmosphere is nearly 800 tons we'd need
at least 14 times more Rockets to handle
just today's nuclear waste let alone get
rid of the hundreds of thousands of tons
in temporary storage we would need to
create entire new Space Industries to
keep up with the demand for giant toxic
Space trash trucks and it gets worse
problem two space is hard
we only made the calculation for low
earth orbit where we send most of our
rockets and satellites
littering the space around Earth with
thousands of casts have spent nuclear
fuel would be a nightmare for space junk
management and satellite collision
avoidance
were still at this altitude there's
still a little bit of atmosphere causing
a tiny bit of drag so we might have
nuclear waste raining down from space
within just a few years experts would
call this a huge problem clearly we have
to launch our waste further if we wanted
to send it to perhaps the moon we either
need way more Rockets or we need to
build much bigger ones making it even
more expensive a single Saturn V the
rocket used by the Apollo program which
cost around 1.5 billion adjusted for
inflation per launch could get about
43.5 tons from the Earth to the Moon
so we'd need about 260 Saturn V rocket
launches every year and of course using
the moon as target practice for nuclear
waste tipped Rockets kind of makes a
huge mess
so maybe don't aim for anything space is
empty do we really need a Target
shooting waste in any random direction
is you guessed it also a bad idea orbits
are Loops which means they have a
tendency to come back to where they
started hot enough in the sky in random
directions and you'll get one back
eventually
so we'd want to launch our nuclear waste
deep into space which means we need even
bigger rockets that would be even more
expensive
not that we would be completely safe
then
Earth might run into these
interplanetary caskets at some time in
the far future and experience a pretty
meteor shower made from radioactive dust
okay how about we shoot it into the sun
ironically the sun is pretty hard to hit
while the sun has very strong gravity
everything on Earth is moving with
respect to the Sun including the rockets
that we launch meaning a rocket would
have to cancel out all the orbital
motion it has around the Sun so it can
stop orbiting and fall in because of
this it's actually easier to launch a
rocket entirely out of the solar system
than it is to launch it into the sun
but to do either of these things we need
even bigger Rockets probably the biggest
we've ever built
hmm
works
the thing is it gets even worse
problem three rockets go
rocket engineering has taken huge steps
since the Apollo era we've made them
relatively safe we've mostly replaced
the toxic explosive cancer fuels of the
past decades with much sailor mixes of
liquid oxygen and hydrogen or kerosene
the newest designs even land themselves
so that they can be reused
and yet out of the 146 launches in 2021
there were 11 failures which means that
a sizable number of our Rockets carrying
high-level radioactive waste would be
exploding on the launch pad or in the
worst case disassembling at high
altitude or crashing from Hypersonic
speeds each failure would be at least
equivalent to a miniature Noble but
instead of being contained under a slab
of concrete spread throughout the
atmosphere radioactive particles could
make their way to far away places by
riding on the winds most would fall into
the ocean but some would land on the
inhabited parts of the world
they could cover farmlands and get
concentrated into our food or enter our
water supply which is well bad imagine
regular large-scale nuclear disasters
happening people wouldn't be happy
conclusion and opinion part
nuclear waste is scary but the fear of
it and horrible ideas like shooting it
into space reveals how bad we are at
understanding risk because the largest
amounts of radioactive elements like
uranium and radon are actually released
by coal burning millions of tons of coal
each year leaves Ash as a waste product
that includes about 36 000 tons of
radioactive materials
less radioactive than high-level nuclear
waste but there's also a lot more of it
and it's handled way less carefully
some of this hash is caught by filters
but most is simply pushed back into
leaky mines shoved into piles exposed to
the wind or poured into ponds that
regularly spilled into rivers and lakes
living within 1.6 kilometers of an ash
pile increases your cancer risk up to 2
000 times over the acceptable limit and
this is on top of other toxic chemicals
like heavy metals and of course their
massive CO2 emissions
and yet while nuclear energy is flawed
and its current form may only be a
transitory technology nuclear power
plants are a harder cell than coal
nuclear waste and the lack of
willingness to deal with it are a real
issue it's not insurmountable though
there are good methods to handle it like
burying it deep underground or
reprocessing some of it into new fuel
but however we ultimately deal with this
issue we hope one thing is clear
shooting nuclear waste into space is one
of the worst ideas ever
researching this crazy thing conducting
all of these important tests and of
course creating this video took us
around 2 000 hours which is insane for a
YouTube video
and we couldn't do it without you if you
like what you just saw you can continue
your science Journey with one of our
products they're true pieces of course
gazards you can take home and touch and
they're the best way to support this
channel like our limited edition human
error calendar that will bring you a
whole year of Joy learn more about the
world with our carefully researched
infographic posters get our habit and
gratitude journals to improve your life
with science or update your wardrobe
with our new hoodie additions if your
room is in need of a literal glow up get
one of these posters we've also got
notebooks plushies mugs and more all
designed with love and produced with
Care by us at codskazart and if you sign
up to our newsletter we'll keep you up
to date on everything happening in the
courts gazarked Universe thank you so so
much for your support
right
[Music]